welcome to this video against paranoid
from the UK ok so the Dutch defense go
for this line down something a little
bit offbeat I'd like to get people away
from the from the Dutch Leningrad I
don't really know that too well with
white zone okay you can actually think
of capturing them maybe after years
committed to c6 this is getting a little
bit more attractive knight c6 setups are
out of the picture
surprising that here now is that maybe
it's not a big deal of course but rather
would have played h5 maybe I don't know
it doesn't doesn't look good in any case
but well that's that's kind of it comes
with the territory within the Dutch
defense you sometimes have those
slightly yeah let's say weird positions
for a nonclassical that look strange for
classical player like me was looking at
my center and having everything kind of
yeah tied it up nicely so what about
this here takes takes g4 why not check
if he takes a tick g6 was chick that
cannot be bad really and 12 okay check
let's see Queen f4 for Bishop f5 yeah
that looks it looks right trading this
Bishop would be great and also would
basically almost win the chief did the
the g4 pawn plus it prevents King c7 so
that looks like it would move
yeah I can take the pawn I don't know if
I should though I can give the check
first that's a good idea probably King
b6 looks kind of wacky maybe he has to
do that though I don't know in going
back looks very very very very bleak ok
let's not grab this pawn and I can't
castle long next
yeah he wants to play a five year and
try to prevent that for a little bit
my washing machine is rather loud them
so if I give the check here where is he
going check we cannot go to c7 so he has
to step ahead so i go here with tempo I
have this coming up it's also possibly
44 e 44 Queen a three years is a good
move b5 might come though okay let's
let's start with that not sure about 94
maybe I should have just played
something something simple
I think it's good though if i get to see
7's also Queen g7 has a pretty big
threat yeah here I can take take g7 g7
take C 2 takes d7 let's take their tix
it takes on each I take d7 it takes f 2
I have 95 check there that should win I
would be weird if not so taking here and
then drinking check check check yeah
everything else yeah that's not going to
work so night check check so let's see
them starting with King with Queen here
right check check black resigns hmm yeah
that was an opening opening disaster I'm
not sure that you want to allow h5 to
happen this already looks kind of
critical to me let's pressure on black
what do you don't know like this this
yeah after check this yet it already
looks very problematic he's losing a
porno by force and it's a bad position
check check you know night f4 was also
good to put check and white wins yeah
that was very straightforward one little
problem here was also from a theoretical
point of view that
black um well there is this line where
black normally plays with knight c6 then
Bishop to e6 Queen to d7 and this is can
DISA sad as factory I went here and now
i can get to this position and he has
this knight c6 setup yeah now no it's
not possible anymore I think that white
is better him looks like why does a bit
better him but I was wondering maybe he
really should should play this move it
looks a bit strange but he I think he
has to prevent prevent age 5 okay well
thanks for watching